are you picking up Deus Ex mankind  divided next week if you want a head  start you should also download Deus Ex  go on your phone or tablet I'm Tony and  this is your augmented gamespot news  update completing certain challenges in  Deus Ex Go will unlock points you can  drop into your skill tree and mankind  divided log into the mobile game with  your Square Enix ID and you'll earn  praxis kits for said challenges link  your account to mankind divided and you  can open those kits for sweet skill  points note that this bonus is only  available in the Xbox one and PC  versions of the game we've contacted  Square Enix to figure out why ps4 is  getting the cold shoulder stay you sex  mankind divided launches next Tuesday  August 23rd Deus Ex go is available  right now on iOS and Android devices  we gave the mobile game an 8 out of 10  so even if you don't go after the Praxis  kits it's still worth playing to keep up  with all the biggest Deus Ex news stick  with GameSpot